good morning we're gonna begin
we'll see representative tucker for
representative hatch
you know promotion on the minutes
second
motion by prentice second by lang
any additions deletions or corrections
to the minutes
seeing none all in favor any opposed
a motion on the
consent agenda
second
and are we removing anything from the
consent agenda
no sir
okay
item number three fp 2021-1112
i'm sorry 1-1-2
there was a request to remove that from
the consent agenda
okay
all those in favor on consent agenda
any opposed
mr chairman who was a second on that
motion
on the regular agenda
[Music]
department of health and human services
for
rule 120.
this is a conditional approval for
2021-120
it is regarding in-home supports
there has been public testimony filed
and i have reviewed the rule the
conditional approval
request
the public testimony the department's
1915 c waiver in regard to in-home
supports
and the department's um corrective
action plan and at this time i have no
basis for gel cart objection
is the department represented
good morning allison zeno administrator
of the administrative rules unit for the
department of health and human services
good morning melissa nemeth i am the
attorney for the bureau of developmental
services you have anything to add on
120.
no sir motion
move to approve
second
motion by laying second by gray any
discussion
all those in favor
any opposed
130.
yes sir um this is a
the proposal is regarding health care
facility discharge data and there's only
one issue to bring to the committee's
attention which is on page seven of the
linked pdf
the rule expired in 2017
however the
originating statute rsa 126 9 has a
civil penalty of 100 per day for
non-compliance so the agency can enforce
compliance without the rule in place
but didn't know whether or not the
committee may have any questions for the
department
good morning again for the record
allison zeno administrator of the
administrative rules unit for the
department of health and human services
jacques chawla bureau chief of public
health statistical informatics in the
division of public health services
um so it's my understanding
that
um although the rules expired uh
pursuant to rsa 126 25
roman 2a
does list out some requirements that the
department can collect in statute and as
attorney roof had said there is
allowance in the statue as well to
collect a civil penance penalty
for non-compliance of that portion and
at this time that's the only portion
of data that the department is
collecting
carolyn virtue is this is this the rule
you honored this
role of week chairman
okay
okay let's finish up with 130
questions from the committee
motion move to approve uh 21 130
motion by landing second by gray any
discussion
seeing none all in favor aye aye
and any opposed
and let's go back to 120
and hear from
carolyn virtue
mr chairman
excuse me
would you like a motion to reconsider
sure
having voted on the prevailing side i
moved would reconsider
all in favor aye
okay go ahead
is the microphone on i apologize thank
you mr chairman members of the committee
i appreciate you allowing me the
opportunity
to speak here today i have submitted
testimony which i believe is included
in the packet
i
will not um
read that chapter and verse
in
an effort to
be brief i also
have one other thing to add which i will
do at the end
um
the rule as it appears before you
does not adequately provide the services
provided to the recipients of the waiver
i spoke only to the service that i
myself provide in a different waiver not
in this waiver just to be clear i do not
provide services in this waiver nor do i
have any intention of ever doing so the
rule impacts the state's costs for
long-term care
as well as the state's reliance on a 50
funding match the match is jeopardized
when services are not provided in
accordance with federal guidance
the department testified during the
course of this that the reason
for
not including
the
definitions in the rule
is that they have another process going
on
simultaneously where they are developing
a manual
and
the
manual will
define
the services
i
do not think the department should be
allowed to rely on an alternate process
so for example to develop rules because
the legislative input and the consumer
input is not as robust so i've included
in your packet
the
manual the draft manual i should say
draft
which has a very robust definition of
service coordination that i could
support
so
i'd like to understand why we can't
have that in rule and to have it be
approved
by this committee
um
you brought this all up at the public
hearing
i brought this all up as chair of the
medical care advisory committee i
participated in the
sub committee on this rule
these suggestions were made to the
department
as i was um working
on
another
issue yesterday
um
i came across an error in the rule
and
it's in 5
there is a sentence about whether or not
remote services
should be provided in hospitals and it
doesn't say
cannot it says that they can i believe
that's an error and that would be in
letter d
in regard to remote services
there are currently many many bills
pending in both bodies of the
legislature in regard to telehealth
there are two bills specifically
senate bill 390 and senate bill 430
which
grossly paraphrasing here set out
guidance for the provision of
telehealth
i think
calling
something remote
when what it actually is is
telehealth
is is a slippery slope it's what what
they're defining as acute and remote
services is telehealth it was
discussed as telehealth but the word
telehealth is missing
from the rule so i am very concerned
that the other work these bodies are
doing on telehealth would not apply to
this
the other
problem with the use of the term
remote services
is that remote services are defined in
the um
and there are codes for them
in the medicaid coding manual
where telehealth is a modality for the
delivery of services
and that should
be a modifier to the service that we're
delivering
so
the the language used in the
acute and remote services section
is hugely problematic and inconsistent
with work being done by this body
and i thank you for your time i would be
happy to take any questions okay next
we're going to hear from mindy hawkins
and sarah kutrubas who
oppose the rule also
thank you mr chairman
and members of the committee
good morning members of the committee
and chairman reagan
for the record my name is sarah katrubus
and i work for community bridges i
represent
them as an area agency that supports
people with developmental disabilities
here in new hampshire
and i am mindy hawkins
senior director of family and
participant directed services at
gateway's community services the area
agency does me in the greater nashua
area
sure i'm here today to address two
concerns with the 524 that is proposed
today
um we did i did provide this
recommendation in writing and received
receipt from messino
on january 10th and when the final rule
that's before you today came out we did
not see changes based on those
recommendations and i'm here today to
speak about two areas
the first area is um
524.03 which indicates that a functional
screen will be required within three
days of eligibility to in-home support
there are questions in the way the 524
is written about what determines the
eligibility date
the response we also received from
attorney nimmith as well as what's
written in the 52403 indicates that it's
when they became eligible for early
supports and services or the
developmental disability waiver
in some cases those individuals might
have became eligible five or six years
ago before they ask for an in-home
supports waiver service
and it says that we must also submit
the two factors which is a statewide
assessment meaning eligibility on that
the functional screen is required to
determine level of care in the
in-home supports waiver that was
approved by the center by the center of
medicaid and medicare services it
indicates the functional screen will be
completed as part of the prior
authorization packet including the
service agreement the budget and the
functional screen
the functional screen when it is
submitted for the first time must be
signed off by an rn
so the concern is is that we're
completing a functional screen when we
have not done a person-centered plan as
required in the in-home supports waiver
we have not done the health risk
screening tool assessment which provides
formal assessment for us to base the
level of care on in which that we're
documenting the functional screen
if i give a functional screen to a nurse
with no
service agreement and no assessment how
is that nurse to determine and sign off
that the functional screen is met it's
merely speaking with the family and
checking off the boxes and it creates a
vulnerability the recommendation
provided in writing was that we continue
to provide the functional screen with
the service agreement and the assessed
tool at time of application for the
in-home supports waiver and that was not
supported or documented in the proposed
rule in front of you
can i just add one thing um just to kind
of break it down even further
excuse me
what
what we are recommending or what we're
asking for you to recommend is that
this all be done in the way that it's
done now
simply because the this
this in-home support waiver is not
offered to every child who is eligible
for area agency services these are
waivered services for children
and it's important to note that there
are limited slots and limited
um money
for these services so if we were to do
this at the intake the original intake
what our what our concern is is that
every family then now understands that
they may be eligible for the in-home
support waiver
and that we will have to add them then
to the registry
and put them on a waiting list for those
services because those slots are so
limited for children so whereas now we
are getting to know families we're
starting to understand what it is that
they need
and only then
would we offer potentially this waiver
service to them based on their needs
instead what we fear will happen is that
every family when hearing about
the great supports offered in the
in-home support waiver they too will
want them and then all of a sudden in a
year from now i will be sitting in front
of a lot of you during the budget and
saying we need more money we need more
slots
because all of these people want this
service
um and so that i just want to put that
kind of bug in your ear that this is a
potential increase
in
cost and the individuals have to have
medicaid to enter this program when they
come in through eligibility they may not
have medicaid and we're completing a
functional screen that allows them to
build medicaid for this waiver and so
families may also be confused that
they're now eligible but until they
obtain medicaid they're truly not
eligible and so it should be at that
juncture that we put them on the
registry based on their assessment
though families do know about this
service and it's part of our service
array when they come into the area
agency system
the second area that we're looking to
ask for your support in today is around
some language in the 524
0.20 around in-home support service
agreements
there is a section three which indicates
that the service coordinator shall visit
the individual and contact the guardian
in person or through video call at least
quarterly
the in-home supports waiver that is
approved by the center for medicaid and
medicare services requires monthly
contact either in person or via phone
contact it does require quarterly
documentation of satisfaction in a
number of areas and it does require on
page 130 that the family or participant
indicate how many in-person home visits
they would like to select with a minimum
of two
as the minimum standard
this uh asks to have us visit quarterly
is not reflected in the in-home supports
waiver it does not
mention the
503.110 where this is mentioned where
the rest of the waiver indicates that
the center of medicaid and medicare
services is not looking for us to report
on quarterly face-to-face
meetings with families they're looking
for us to provide them monthly contact
quarterly documentation of satisfaction
and a minimum of two home visits this
would be an additional burden we
understand that at times we're asked to
do more one of the biggest complaints
we're getting from families right now is
that with the increased
oversight from the center of medicaid
and medicare services and at times from
our bureau of developmental services is
that their service coordination feels
more like checking boxes and less like
having that expert who really knows
their family and is using a
person-centered approach to address
issues that affect them immediately and
that will change their lives which is
truly the responsibility of service
coordination when we ask for these
additional things that are not required
by the waiver it takes away our ability
to focus on the things the families
actually are asking us to help them with
and it does not put our medicaid match
at risk because center of medicaid and
medicare services is not asking for that
or looking for that because we did not
commit to that in our waiver so we're
asking this committee to
keep
the requirements of the 524 face-to-face
to what is documented clearly in the
waiver submitted
let's have a motion for an objection to
the rule based on the testimony um
senator i just have one question what
what rule are you referring to can you
give me the citation again for that one
with the quarterly
yes it's it's currently in your
proposed 524 under 524.20
number three
and if i may just add one other
unlimited objective
thank you
second
motion by laying second by bursting
discussion
all those in favor
any
opposed
the motion carries thank you thank you
thank you
senator rager i'm sorry i'm not sure
that the testimony given was given on
the correct version
and
you can interrogate the witnesses and
find out what they're
i'm just i'm having trouble finding
exactly what they're talking to
um as
maybe alison can help clarify i'm not
sure
mr chair
so i did find that i had a question but
i think i figured in a preliminary
objection they could fix it but there
was
in the section they were talking about
that does talk about quarterly visits
the individual but then it talks
section two right above it talks about
monthly visits
and so i'm not sure which one applied to
the cms and which one didn't
in the ones that were provided on our
packet it's on page
second in our packet mr chairman mayor
excuse me uh the comments you're making
are they to the final proposal or to the
conditional approval request
it should say in the header of the rule
it's the final rule the final version
well
it was someone directed to us by the
department there is if at the very top
in the right hand corner does it say
conditional approval request for 222.
i'm sorry i did not bring i'm i'm
specifically quoting um a response from
attorney nimitz that was sent to us
quoting the current final rule on april
13th
okay so that should be this
okay
i believe it to be the final um
it's under specifically under in-home
support service agreement section
all right i found it
thank you thank you again
board of occupational therapists
okay this proposal makes changes to the
licensing rules for occupational
therapists
the board has filed a conditional
approval request which you do have
linked on your agenda
that conditional approval request pretty
much
resolves all of the concerns
there is one issue and um
it's regarding a citation to an allied
health rule
regarding the licensing fee and the
comment
occurs in several places but if you look
on page two
you go to that
you will find the first instance of the
comment
and so here
what the issue is is that
that rule at the allied health rule at
301.02 doesn't actually contain any
licensing fees for occupational
therapists it's written as if it's just
for licensure and certification of
speech language assistance so in
conversation with tina kelly from oplc
they are aware of this issue and plan to
bring this forward to the allied health
board at their next meeting so that they
can consider some rulemaking to
fix that section of the rule and tina is
here and can speak more about that issue
good morning i'm tina kelly from the
office of professional licensure and
certification i'm a program specialist
and in ahp 301.02 which addresses the
fees for all of the allied health boards
the header says schedule fees for
licensure and for certification of
speech language
assistance it was meant to be both the
licensees and the speech language
assistance
so if you read it all together it makes
it sound like it's just for licensure
and certification of speech language
assistance but it's meant for both and
if you look at the
the table of the um fees it does
specifically say licensure and
certification so but i'm going to take
that back to the board of directors of
the allied health professionals they
meet on 428 of 2022
um and rework that opening sentence and
submit rules to clarify
okay
so they're gonna run out of time
no
yeah the deadline is on the 29th of this
month
the committee would need to ask for a
waiver if you plan to um postpone
a motion to waive the deadline
on one three seven
so moved
motion by lane a second by tucker
waiver
any discussion all those in favor
aye
any opposed
the board of pharmacy has requested a
postponement
and
number 104 department of agriculture
markets and food
okay yes sir the agency has filed an
amended objection response and there are
no more staff comments um on that
amended objection response we didn't
place this proposal onto consent in case
the committee had any questions
as you may remember the committee
objected to the proposal based on staff
comments
specifically to language in the rule
that would allow an automatic suspension
of a license uh without notice and
opportunity for a hearing in violation
of rsa
uh 541a30
and
rsa437
the agency
first filed an objection response that
deleted everything in the section
including what was currently in the rule
i mean you can see that in the last
couple of pages of the linked pdf
in the um amended objection response it
pretty much puts the rule back to where
it was before rule making began
and the purpose of the rulemaking was to
address the implementation of house bill
250 from the last session
that would um prohibit the transfer of
animals over i think the numbers over 49
but um we had some back and forth with
the agency and this is where they landed
just to put it back
to where it was and as i said we don't
have any additional comments but we
didn't know if the committee may have
any questions for the agency
good morning center morning committee
steve crawford state veterinarian new
hampshire department of agriculture
questions from the committee
representative mcguire
yes thank you uh mr chair
uh just curious when you are going to
implement that law
uh
we already have the
we're not sure the law didn't require
rule making to implement it created if
you um and i brought it here so i could
read the language
so the legislature changed the
definition of pet vendor
to mean
any entity that transfers 30 or more
dogs cats ferrets etc
all license
and then in 437.3
no pet vendor shall transfer animals
without a license that's always been the
standard
the addition here was that
and it's always been a requirement to
have
proof of zoning before we issue a
license
the legislature in august of last year
uh created a standard that
no lice no zoning proof is required
until someone reaches 50
animals
so we can still issue a license and we
have without zoning approval i think
there are three entities thus far that
have been licensed without zoning
approval no one's reached the 50 yet
so we've begun to to do that we just
haven't gotten to the
and i think the from our discussion with
gelco attorneys
the
process for
someone who reaches 50 animals without
providing
proof of zoning is already in statute in
541 and in our agr 200 rules in terms of
how we handle notifications and hearings
in administrative process
do i understand you correctly that if
someone has a business and they only
sell
animals during a year
they don't need to be licensed so they
don't need zoning approval
yeah so they're essentially three three
levels so 29 animals are less than a
year you don't need to be licensed with
us regulated by us
30 to 49 requires a license without
zoning approval 50 and up requires a
license with zoning approval
i sure hope everybody understands that
we're trying to come we're trying to
come together with it too but thank you
you're done
move to approve second
motion by lying second by mcguire
discussion
all those in favor
any opposed
the rules approved
mr chairman yes on the previous item in
order to postpone that is going to
require a waiver of the committee's
deadline so if you had
if you uh wished a member to
make a motion to postpone and seek a
waiver
so move
motion by mcguire
any discussion on the motion
all those in favor
any opposed
waivers okay
you have any other business uh one item
uh just want to make the committee aware
that starting on may 6 we are going to
have another attorney working for us her
name is rebecca ricard which currently
works at dcyf
we have since sending out the letter
notifying agencies of expiring rules
we are having an uptick in the
rulemaking and it looks like
at the current rate we'll have at least
proposals this year
thank you senator i think we still have
item uh
2021-112
the one-off consent
okay
child care program licensing rules
um as this was on consent the committee
staff have no comments but i believe
there are people here to testify
just come on up if you
pulled out the card
i also think it's um important that i
point out that um one of the people
testifying is actually the owner of the
daycare that my child goes to
um
so just
to put that out there um i don't think
that there is any conflict but um if
if
we decide otherwise one of the other
attorneys can take this
okay
do you wish the test to come out
with this sorry hi my name is kristen
byron i'm owner and director of a child
care center two of them in manchester
um thank you i'm fairly new at doing
this i was hoping to hear the state
speak first
in regards to some of these rules we've
for many years
i've run a child care center and i've
come across
different ways of doing things and try
to be objective of looking at things
but in these particular roles and i was
just told
that it didn't really matter but
a lot of child care centers are at work
right now it's very hard for us to even
get out to be able to come up here and
do this
so i've been trying to listen to a whole
lot of other people and what they're
saying too so bear with me but a big
problem that we're having is this whole
fingerprinting issue
we're all for
wanting safe people to be working with
children
and we know that they should be
fingerprinted and background checked etc
i don't know where exactly in the role
and hopefully melissa can help us out
she said it's a different issue but i do
need to bring it up because before a
person can be working for you they need
to be fingerprinted but the wait time is
so ridiculous that you end up losing
great staff members
um there's got to be a way to fix this i
don't know if anybody has any great
ideas but we're open to that
um
and and maybe like if you can be
fingerprinted in doe you maybe could be
also okay for dhhs and
i don't know how to fix that but that's
a huge problem that one day when i have
more time we will look at
um specific rules that i'd like to look
at today is on page 11.
and that is
basically what's get what gets posted on
the internet um and who and how it gets
determined that was huge
so if we we could look at that a little
bit closer
um
page 26 there's an evacuation plan
i personally was on the phone with my
insurance company for
roughly about an hour
because
my program specifically does not um
ensure children going off premises
and under this specific rule we have to
practice an evacuation off-site bomb
threats once per year
i understand why they might want that
but how do you do that when you're the
owner
and i can't bring the children
off-premises
so i feel as though that rule needs to
be lifted on page 26.
um also on page 13
again i'm sorry these rules are
different than the rule book that we're
using now so i'm going back and forth um
the informal dispute resolution
um we've talked about this
lots and lots of times and i don't see
anything getting changed there
it's basically their word against our
word
until
that's how it goes
um and i just don't like things
personally put on an internet that may
or may not be
true
on a state website
um so the informal dispute resolution
really needs to be looked at further
and also on page 61 i'd like to see
something added
in under
professional developments
i've read a lot of citations that have
been on on the state website and all and
i feel as though maybe some people need
to learn a little bit more what a
corrective um
discipline approach would be for
children of different ages
um
you know and what what you could do with
them so maybe add
to our pro-solution classes
as we have medication and transportation
and things like that maybe something
about appropriate discipline for young
children and make that a mandatory class
did you receive notice of the public
hearing for these rules i did and
unfortunately
um
i'm working about 24 7 as i'm sure other
people are too and i was unable to make
it so
i again these are things that were
brought up there but now here they are
and i just don't i can't just say here
let's pass them because i'm
i'm on the other end but i try to look
at things on both sides
so
thank you for listening i appreciate
your help
sally william weber
good morning members of the committee
and um i am the owner of the tots pot
and i do have
um
um your child at our program and he's
very lovely so thank you um i'd first
like to thank also child care licensing
for the work that they have done to
improve these licensing rules
we've seen a lot of improvements and
they have really heard some of our
feedback but not all of it
the licensing unit had an audit by the
legislative committee you may be aware
of that um
and in that they found that there was
over 1 000
approximately a thousand licensing rules
and for any program on any given day to
know manage and be in compliance
with a thousand licensing rules is
nearly impossible it sets programs up
for failure
and worse than that it sets us up for
violations and infractions which could
lead to fines and potentially program
closures so i'd like to just kind of set
that as the tone
a lot of times
we hear programs talk about over
regulation and certainly
rules that may
overstep
the
discretion
of the program or the business
and so a few of those i wanted to talk
about is hec 4002.11
there is a rule about children who are
ill and sick exclusion from programs
that's on page 17
and essentially what it
indicates is that
children shall not be excluded from
child care
if
they do not meet one of the following
requirements
and they list them out i think for
programs that's really challenging we're
still in a pandemic
and
programs are with most of these children
anywhere from 20 to 50 hours a week
their teachers know them intimately
in terms of the daily interactions and
we need to have the right
as programs and as private businesses to
decide if a child is not well enough to
be on our program and send them home so
my issue is with the word shall shall
means must and you'll hear me say that a
few times during my testimony today so i
just think it's too restrictive and it
removes the discretion of the program
and i think that's
you know i think that's an overstep by
the department so i would request that
that language is specifically amended
to remove shell
in addition to that um on 4002.19g
also tying in with that on page 29 is
about sick children going outside
and it's a mandate that if a child is
ill or not feeling well or perhaps has
an allergy
that the program shall not make them go
outside now our teachers must be in
ratio so for example with toddlers it
might be a one to five or one to six
ratio
well if you have one child whose parent
says they do not want them to go outside
it means that the other five children
cannot be out or that child needs to be
moved to a classroom
where perhaps
they're inside at that time period but
then that might put the program over
ratio so again i feel like programs
really need the ability to have the
discretion to say to the parent if your
child is not well enough
then perhaps
they either need to stay home or you
need to find a program that is a better
fit for your child's needs and your
family because
it just really
compromises our ability to care for the
entire group rather than looking at the
individuality of just one specific child
so
again i think that's just an over
regulation of our programs
throughout the rules
the manual
the rules manual for programs to follow
it is scattered
it needs to be simplified i know that
licensing
the staff have talked about they have
certain administrative rules that they
have to follow and how they format their
rules
but it's not user friendly and so you
might be going from
you know that you
have to have documentation of
immunizations on file and then you skip
to
something that's completely different
and so it's really difficult for
programs to stay in compliance with over
a thousand rules when they're not neatly
grouped together and again i think it
creates a lot of
incidents where things can easily get
missed as legislators none of you
probably would be able to remember
a thousand laws
on every given day
and be able to implement those and speak
to them
and ensure that your staff know every
single one of those rules as well so i
think it's an unrealistic
expectation and
there are a lot of items that i think
could be put into best practice um as
like an appendix
or
another way
to handle some of these
these pieces
um
a big issue that i also have is 42.03
and that's time frames for departmental
response
and essentially
child care licensing
i believe they need to be held to
similar standards that they subject
their licensees to
the time frames and the discrepancies
between
the amount of time that they get to
respond and submit things back to
programs
is inequitable and unreasonable compared
to the many many incidences of time
frames in which license programs are
subject to
one in particular is providing
licensed programs and licensees
their corrective action plan from the
department within 21 days
i would make that recommendation there
is nowhere that i saw in the licensing
rules that they have a set time frame so
initially we that we have our monitoring
visit
and then within 21 days the licensors
were required to send us our statement
of findings in my case in 2021
the licensor came in july at the end of
july and i didn't get my statement of
findings until the end of september
that far exceeds the 21 days
we need some measure of accountability
for the department when they don't meet
their own time frames
in addition to that my particular
statement of findings was incorrect
the wrong rules were cited i requested
that they reissue me a correct statement
of findings
and that did not happen until mid
november
i responded with my corrective action
plan which mind you um
my licensing visit was july 28th i
resolved the issue the 20 sorry the 27th
i resolved the issue the 28th i sent
them a letter i sent them the truth and
said this is proof of my corrective
action so i did it the very next day and
it was relative to fingerprinting my
employee could not get fingerprinted
because
everyone was shut down
so long made short
i submitted my
corrective action plan once the
statement of findings was corrected
i still have not received a res an
official response back from the
department and this morning to my shock
i went on just to double check
and i found
that my corrective action plan was
posted to the internet without my
knowledge
and that was done on december 1st
the law states in 170e that they're
supposed to notify us six days in
advance i wasn't notified i still don't
have an official copy and this is
required to be posted at my center for
parents to review
and for when the licensor comes
i'm not able to be in compliance because
the department has not done their job
this is not an anomaly i'm not the only
program this happens to anecdotally i
hear from programs over and over again
that the time frames in which the
department responds is inadequate
sometimes it's taking months and months
and sometimes almost up to a year
for us to get necessary paperwork back
for us to be in compliance
so i would ask respectfully that the
committee hold licensing accountable
and require that they have a 21 day
because that's pretty consistent with
42.6 d
and with g 21 days is we have 21 days to
get our plan in they have 21 days i
would ask that they have to have 21 days
to get our corrective action plan back
because it's not reasonable that we're
hanging out to dry and waiting and
waiting and waiting
and i don't believe that it should be
the sole onus of the program to
repeatedly follow up with and notify
cclu that we have not received our
paperwork back
so
um i think that's really important and i
think that ties in with what kristen
byron talked about having things posted
to the internet now granted
my corrective action plan was fine and
they approved it but they should have
notified me i shouldn't have gone on and
been surprised to find
that on december 1st
that they had posted it three days
within receiving it from their office
both electronically and through
certified mail
so i just you know i i think we need to
have
fairness and equity amongst
time frames and responses
and then the other thing i wanted to
talk about
i know there's a lot of discussion about
fingerprinting is
set by the
child development block grant
from the federal government
however in our state statute 170 e7 4a
and 4d
we are required to have eligibility
cards eligibility card is simply proof
that your staff has been fingerprinted
and they've cleared their background
checks
now while the fee is set in stone in 170
e for fifty dollars
the language says that the department
may
issue an eligibility card may is not
shall it is not must it creates a
tremendous burden on
the individual worker who may make
anywhere from twelve dollars an hour on
average
and i also think it creates an increased
burden on programs i've probably spent
close to seven hundred to a thousand
dollars
in this in the past year or so trying to
onboard staff who may
not even show up to their job but we've
already submitted the paperwork and the
department has cashed our check
or what happens is i probably have three
to five employees
that were fingerprinted in 2021 between
probably
july and september
and none of those individuals have
received their eligibility card from the
department so i have paid the fifty
dollars a piece for them
the department has cashed my check and
they have not sent an eligibility card
for them so my question for you is how
long have you been in
i've been a business for 10 years for 10
years and how many people have failed
their background checks um and that i
have hired yes
none we had one individual who's kristen
have you had any
no
yeah right yep and so for the
eligibility cards um the state is taking
our money but they're not providing us
with the service or the card
and we again statute
according to licensing rules we're
required to have a copy of that
eligibility on card eligibility card on
file
so um i would actually ask that the
committee
make the decision to override
dhhs and not require the eligibility
card at this time the statute says may
it does not require it just requires the
fee
and then just
just to lastly wrap up and i thank you
for your time um
we are i'm sure many of you have seen
this in the news i know many of you said
on other committees we are in a dire
workforce crisis
um the fissures and cracks have become
canyons in terms of
our ability to find staff let alone
qualified staff according to licensing
standards
graciously intelligently the legislature
gave us a huge win
with
modifying and putting into statute the
requirements of an associate level
teacher
however it still does not go far enough
programs like mine
are suffering we are on the brink of
closing because we do not have staff it
is the worst i've seen in 10 years and
i'm sure kristen who has been in
business way longer than me
can tell you programs like ours never
went understaffed we did not have
problem finding employees and we do now
i've had positions and i know colleagues
that have had positions open for well
over a year
and even when we are offering
middle to high wages five weeks paid off
vacation 500 sign-on bonuses
we are not getting applicants so i would
ask and we have approached licensing
repeatedly to say
give us some leeway on the assistance
they are not allowed to be left alone
with children unless it's say
walking a child to the bathroom
transferring them between classrooms
sitting with them when
they're waiting for a parent when
they're sick
i'm not suggesting that someone who has
no education or experience should be
solely left alone with children
however
we need people to fill these spots and
we have
loving caring parents who have life
experience
but they don't have college you know
they may not have the college credits or
they may not have been in a certain
position
that rises to the level that they could
be associate qualified per the
definition of the the legislation's
definition of associate teacher
allowing us to have a little bit more
broad leeway with assistance in a
classroom say
being able to sit alone with a child
or a class during nap time providing
that there's other qualified individuals
or staff in the building would go a long
way
we need something more
to fill and to create a stop gap for for
the crisis that we're experiencing and
it's
insurmountable
um the stress that it creates for
business owners the burnout that it's
creating amongst their colleagues for
losing people life right and left um
they can go to target and work for you
know twenty dollars an hour or
mcdonald's for seventeen
um so the the field is not appealing
right now and we are doing everything we
can
and for programs that have tuition as
their sole source of income
they cannot afford to pay high wages
we can't find substitutes even to cover
when people are out sick
so i really would encourage the
committee to to press
and impress upon licensing that we they
need to do more
and it's not so much about we want
quality applicants
absolutely we do we want educated
applicants
but if we do not have workers in our
child cares
programs
parents are not going to have child care
because they will continue to close
and we have seen the numbers go down
drastically from how many licensed
programs there were even
four or five years ago and at one point
we were closer to a thousand and i think
now we might be under 700
and licensing will tell you that some of
those switched hands and some of them
consolidated but a lot of it is that
people are tired of the over regulation
the overreach of licensing rules and
they can't
they can't make ends meet
with the restrictions that are upon them
and times have changed and they were
changing before covid so this is not a
covet issue
so um i sorry i'm sorry for taking so
long i have testified at public hearings
i have given my input to licensing
and i feel like this is kind of the last
measure because
although licensing
i'm hoping that they are looking forward
and will be willing to work more
collaboratively
continue to be more collaborative with
programs
but our history shows us that we have
we have made the battle cries and they
have not responded representative
mcguire so yes thank you i like to
comment that the requirements for
lowest level of staff
is a policy
fight that's been going on between
people that want to have
more
individuals involved in child care like
you say the parents with life experience
and those who think it should be a
profession that requires significant
academic
background
and
we've tried there have been
various occasions over the last few
years to expand the scope of life
experience yes but it keeps
it's it's never quite enough i'm afraid
and
if we
it is a problem that we keep seeing that
the
you're you're running into a difference
of what quality is
and and of course the trade-off between
quality and quantity
i'm sorry that you're stuck in a bind
but you are not alone
yes i know and i can tell you from the
10 years that i have been
in this field
i have had staff with master's degrees
and after hiring them i
am shocked at their inability to connect
with children their lack of common sense
and i have had
um
substitutes and assistants um and young
young ladies who have worked with me
that
are loving caring compassionate and they
do really really well with children and
i would pick them any day over the week
than someone
sometimes with a lot of experience
because they don't always know how to
put that into practice
okay is there anyone here from licensing
are you through with me yes thank you
thank you so much
just for the record alison zino
administrator of the administrative
rules unit for the health and human
services
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee i'm melissa clement and i'm
the chief of the child care licensing
unit
is there any particular
place you want me to start or should i
just want me to address what we've heard
so far
well just re respond to it sure
um so
to respond to
kristen byron who spoke first regarding
the fingerprinting
and
the concerns there
the fingerprinting is a federal
requirement the appointments come
through the division of state police so
we are and we don't have control over
how
when those appointments are available
how often they are so what's their
response to you when you say that these
people can't operate their businesses
because they can't get fingerprinted
we've been working with state police in
order to
try to speed up their
a their ability to have appointments i
know the state police have
received money in order to obtain 11
more of the fingerprinting machines so
they can be placed around the state and
they're working on implementing that my
understanding is is that there's always
an appointment pretty much within a week
of when someone goes to make an
appointment through the state police and
there's state police appointments
there's also appointments available at
local police departments depending on
the community you're in
so programs usually can get an
appointment within a week they may have
to travel for that because they're
scattered around the state but they are
available
it's not soon enough i i understand the
pain that the child care programs are
going through i'm hopeful that these
additional machines when they come on
board will help increase the
availability of appointments um but my
understanding is there is usually within
a week depending on where you are in the
state you can get those appointments
um
it's
it's a requirement for the federal
government that everyone have those
background record checks um kristin also
spoke to
an ability to use the department of
education we're not able to do that
because the results of those background
record checks have to come to the
department of health and human services
and the fbi requirements do not allow
the sharing of fingerprint results so if
a fingerprint result was taken
for us
school educate sau if they were done at
that level they can't then share that
those results with us we're required to
receive the results so it's a federal
requirement that we're not able to
change
and i know this
child care providers are working with
our representatives at the federal level
to try to make some adjustments but
that's the federal rule at this time
there's also
a
we're creating a study committee to look
at the prospect of centralizing such
records checks in education because it
is absolutely insane
that
yes
somebody that happens to work
in more than one
position that requires a background
check should have to get a separate
background check for every single
position because we
the department of education can't tell
the department health and human services
yes this person is is clear
and
it may be a federal requirement but it's
an incredibly silly and inc and
and it's a ridiculous requirement so
we're
i know we're looking into it because
uh
that's a concern for a lot of people i
am very happy to help with any study
committee that you have on this um
there's an additional wrinkle with our
requirements through the office of child
care because we're required to do what's
called a national crime information
center check of the
sex offender file that rests with the
fbi and that our federal requirement
that is the only way you can get that is
through
a state police or a government agency
it's a law agency so department of ed
doesn't have access to check that one
file that we are required to check so i
certainly i am all for trying to
increase the ability for us to share
results but that is an additional
wrinkle that we have as the department
of health and human services and i'm
happy to help do your
uh excuse mr jim
the do those
access cards you give out after someone
is fingerprinted include the result of
this background check it what it says is
that you're eligible to work in child
care so the card itself shows that we
have done our fbi checks those and the
nci check our abuse and neglect checks
all of those checks and a person can use
that for multiple employers yes
multiple employees for license like
child care licensed child care
absolutely that that's the purpose of it
so that
um employees will have that when they go
for a job interview to say you can see
that i'm current
and
and to follow up is that
are why why are there cases where you
haven't sent those out
we're working through our backlog we had
system changes last summer with our new
system and we are
some of it has to it's a multi-prong
issue some of it has to do with our
um
has to do with the state police and us
getting results from them because they
shifted to their online portal for their
results last year we are working with
state police we have a spreadsheet on
people that we are working on getting
those results and making sure that we
can issue the cards
and one thing i want to impress is that
i am first hearing today from mrs
willenweber that she hasn't received the
cards um she
i haven't heard that i know she i'm sure
she has communicated in people into my
department and i will definitely go back
and check in with them on that issue but
if she had reached out to me directly
which i have
told providers many times we are working
through these issues and and i will be
on that as soon as i get back to the
office so i can provide her with an
answer
the
fees for the background record checks
that are currently in statute are
actually in senate bill or 30 right now
to be reduced from 50 dollars to 25
dollars
so i just wanted to bring that up as
well we are working for that relief the
reason in statute why we have may
instead of shall
is we did not want to require everybody
who works for a child care program to
have to have one of those cards we were
looking at it more for the teachers and
the workforce
a lot of programs hire
janitorial staff so they're not going to
be hopping from child care program to
child care program to work they're
working for that one program we didn't
there's no need for them to have one of
those cards so that's why in statute it
is made instead of shall we want it to
have flexibility as to who and it's that
that is stated in rule as to who is
required to obtain a card and who is not
mike
mr chairman um
the public testimony you heard it was
compelling and
discussed some important issues but i
think it addressed policy issues
not bases for objection and i think many
of those issues may require statutory
changes yes
yes
so do you folks understand that things
that you think we can do we can't do and
that there has to be changes in statute
don't leave until i speak to you
so
we understand the distress you're in
and
these are things that require statutory
changes
in order to force
the agencies
to do things
faster better
so
um can i speak to something
and when you're talking about the stress
um
like um
representative mcguire stated we had
changed the associate teacher that is
now what's involved in this rule that
statutory change has been adopted a rule
we sent out guidance last october when
it was effective for programs to start
using that
i
although i i i do completely understand
the stress programs are under i don't
think the qualifications is where the
stress lies there are workforce
shortages across the state in many
industries
i don't think lowering the standards of
the our
qualified staff is going to change
what
the amount of applicants that they
receive in addition to that we have a
waiver process i review and approve
waivers daily about they found someone
that they really liked and they want to
be able to hire them and have them work
in the position that they're hiring for
and we give them time to come into
compliance like you know we'll give them
a year to take the courses they need to
take or the training they need to have
that is something that we do regularly
all the time and i am happy to entertain
any waiver that a program brings to me
when they feel they have found the right
candidate
what are options
the committee can approve the rule if
you feel there's a basis for objection
you may object
of all the things i've heard today i
think the most concerning is
the
statements by the people who run the
daycare uh centers that they're not
hearing with the 21 days in other words
it's not an equal
accountability on
response time and i wondered if we
wouldn't want to give the agency a
chance to respond to that
so that 21 day response time is now in
the rule so that was and that was a new
statutory change and something that we
are implementing with this rule
so are you finding that you're able
could i do a follow-up
are you able to uh respond within 21
days to the centers
we are certainly gearing up for that and
we once the rules pass that will
absolutely be what we are doing
we have we have definitely speeded up
our response time we are implementing um
a new system which will be live in
several months which will allow us to
have that response times be much quicker
but until then we have other processes
in place so that we are ensuring that we
are getting those visits out
i can see that that would be
particularly irritating
yes
thank you
just just for information um
house bill 1507 which requires
investigatory program findings to be
timely published has passed the house
and is on the consent calendar in the
senate so that should set the timelines
more equitably i hope
if i may um my name is dorian shockley i
am the manager of the bureau of
licensing and certification at the
department of health and human services
overseeing all licensed facilities from
birth to end of life
and to the question regarding timeliness
it is something that has come up
numerous times over the course of the
last two to three years we have worked
very diligently to improve our own
response time we agree with the
community that we need to be held
accountable
we as
we've talked numerous times about um
[Music]
um we also struggle with workforce um
our support team
usually is five people it currently is
two
um and as the manager i've stepped in as
well and i can tell you with um
with um personal experience since
december our response time um has been
with it within 14 to
21 days so we have in fact improved that
so i wanted to be very clear melissa
she's been involved in other things
hasn't been as involved in the support
and the response time but i have been
based on the comments from the community
so i just wanted to make that perfectly
clear that we are committed to that
thank you thank you i also would like to
add um the
response time in the rule 402.03 of
60 days is actually a 541a requirement
and it's um that the department must
respond no later than 60 days um if that
if
the committee wants that
to be changed they would need to do that
in the rule but it's not a
it's not a minimum requirement it's a
maximum requirement
good morning members of the committee if
i may i am deborah nelson i am the
bureau chief for child development and
head start collaboration and we
administer the child care and
development block grant funds as well as
the head start collaboration office and
we are really invested in supporting the
passage of this rule because if not we
face potential very stiff financial
penalties because much of the finite
much of the federal requirements that
are in federal law for the child care
and development block grant
are going to be addressed in this rule
we had our first ever on state on-site
monitoring visit last april because the
office of childcare debra did state
on-site visits before and they decided
to start so new hampshire had ours last
april and they uncovered a number of
issues of non-compliance that we really
didn't know we were not in compliance it
was our interpretation of what what the
rule said and what we you know versus
what the federal um administrator said
so we have been give states have been
given technically by september 30 2021
all states were supposed to be in
complete compliance with the 2014
reauthorization from the ccdf block
grant
of course with especially background
checks few states are but we've got some
you know some minor issues but a few
more significant issues especially the
background check which is going to be
covered and put us in compliance when
this rule passes if it doesn't pass and
we we expect to get our letter probably
in the next month or so from the federal
office of child care telling us what
they're going to do to new hampshire if
we're not in compliance and we stand to
lose at least a million or more dollars
so um very concerned that you know we we
do whatever we can i mean i absolutely
you know
my my heart and you know empathy is with
providers over the last year we've
worked closely with licensing and other
professionals in our division of
economic and housing stability to bend
over backwards to do whatever we could
to put in emergency policies to share up
and keep the doors open in child care we
got 143 million dollars of covert relief
funds in my little beer at one point
there were five of us because half were
out you know with the coba themselves um
trying to deal with you know all of
those funds getting money out to
providers uh changing policy to you know
to scale back the rules so that they
could just you know get people in the
door
but now we're in the position of moving
forward in what the federal government
calls the build back even better
phase of the pandemic just trying to you
know shore up for long-term
sustainability of programs but at the
same time we want to make sure that
people can keep their doors open we want
to make sure that that our children and
families are getting high quality
supports and services that are healthy
safe and and support their development
to prepare them for the best success in
school so these rules reflect not just
um not just one but four different
aspects of non-compliances that directly
impact us which then will impact if we
get federal federal penalties i don't
have as much money to put towards child
care scholarship fund for children or as
much money to support programs to to get
their quality even higher and and
support professionals to gain skills
that help them
be more satisfied in their positions
because they feel comfortable in their
positions and have the skills to work
with children we heard about the
challenging behaviors and that whole
issue in the you know the request to
require
certain training around between a
positive behavioral supports we have a
lot of initiatives going on right now
where folks can get free coaching they
can take free online courses um around
they can't do their own fingerprinting
they can't get people they have people
that want jobs and they can't put them
to work so that the parents can go to
work of the children that they take care
of
so let's not confuse it with all the
other
998 regulations so i i understand that
senator i absolutely do and i think as
melissa was saying we've been working
all of us with the department of safety
we've been working with the federal
government we've been working with the
fbi what can we do to address that
problem and with the department of ed we
actually had a joint committee looking
at you know can we share you know what
what can we do to make this easier for
programs so some of it's you know above
our pay grade and over our heads and not
in our peer view but we're certainly
working to resolve it
so apparently if we don't pass the rule
we make things worse
what's the pleasure of the committee
move to the proof
lang moves and tucker seconds to approve
the rule
and
we'll lean on safety
for what
good that might do
we even offered them some some money if
they needed more staffing to help move
things along so you know whatever we can
do to collaborate we're happy to do so
and they indicated they're having
problems with staffing yes
they have to get their background checks
through first
so the state is down about 20
of its total workforce so it's
everybody's
in the same situation
that the operators are so
any discussion on the motion
i'd like to thank uh all the people who
came in to speak
from the provider's point of view
we know vaguely
as individuals about these problems but
really work went into their
presentations and i have a better
grasp of the problems thank you very
much so you've heard the motion all
those in favor aye aye any opposed
so the rules approved but
we're all alerted
to the
to what the distress is so
and i trust the department will consider
making some of the minor corrections
that the uh
operators have suggested
and
can't help with the lice with the
fingerprints but the other details
right they should pay should be
avoidable
thank you thank you okay thank you
ladies
mr chairman would the committee like to
cancel its continued meeting on this yes
we'll cancel the continued meeting
if we have any other business
meeting is adjourned
thank you
you